Vancouver respire enfin après 10
semaines de canicule puis de fumer
étouffante en provenance des feux de
forêt le temps plus frais et claire et
accueilli comme une délivrance mais
l'embellie ne peut faire oublié à quel
point est la question des changements
climatiques est devenu urgent tu es une
priorité pour les électeurs
l'été 2021 et celui de tous les dangers
en Colombie-Britannique plus de 1500
fois en plus les 7000 km carré de forêt
dans Sandro passage le village de l'été
le dôme de chaleur fait plus de 500
personnes selon le Coran nerf de la
province en Colombie-Britannique les
changements climatiques sont devenus des
menaces à la santé publique souligner la
sociation canadienne des médecins pour
l'environnement
pour s'assurer que la un jeu occupe le
plus de place possible dans la campagne
les militaires aux écologistes de
Colombie-Britannique sont déterminés à
se faire voir et entendre il fait 6 et
des nombres groupe qui a gagné seront
des manifestations un peu partout au
pays le 8 septembre jour du débat des
chefs pour appeler urgence climatique et
aussi de faire sortir le vote en faveur
de l'environnement
ici Mathieu Gohier Radio-Canada